tu es en train de parler d'une arme de
la semaine et c'est l'eurovision parce
que vous savez plus révision c'est un
groupe breton qui a été choisie sur sur
france 3 aussi d'autres choses et c'est
une bonne chose effectivement moi
j'adore la bretagne j'adore les bretons
et la musique est très très bien c'est
gai mais évidemment il ya eu un clash
son nom est ce que c'est jennifer ch
apple j'oublie ces résultats qui étaient
ces qui la troisième j'ai bien fini
pourquoi je suis tout le temps n'est que
l'état alors que je les adore et vous
est long il ya eu un clash elles se sont
pas entendus à propos du choix justement
du groupe regarder mais il a une voix
extraordinaire je pense que par moments
on perd un tout petit peu le sens de la
mélodie et non à magrie alors
la voix est là on est d'accord ou pas
[Applaudissements]
le charisme est là ou pas
et les jumelles taylor great big meadow
les faits
je suis pas d'accord avec la première
chose que j'ai gaba d'accord je tenais
mais là non il est très belle voix moi
je maman je vois comme ça pensez vous
qu'ils veulent pas manquer de respect
nous que l'état alors qu'il ait parlé
ici de ce côté là alors ludivine mais
pas du tout mais pas du tout c'est une
showgirl elle est vraiment dans le dans
le temps alors elle est dans l'outrance
dans l'extravagance c'est une drama
queen en fait donc elle est dense dans
un show à l'américaine sur ça qu'elle a
parlé anglais en faisant d'ailleurs des
petites erreurs a les notes de gris ça
ne se dit pas madame idoles que j'aime
énorme mais l'ua direct envoyé un tweet
nicoletta est même revenu dans dans gala
encore c'est qu'il aura autant de tubes
connus que l'état ne
non mais à lui elle lui dit ata donc
évidemment
mais n'ont qu'à passer rester
kaunas
jean-michel non moi je te laisses tu
soit assez pour me dire qu'elle est très
haché en fait qu'elle est qu'il en coûte
bien sûr mais dans ce que tu excuse moi
je suis peut-être un vieux con je voyais
même pas qui c'était quand j'ai vu dans
le jeu originel remplis d'aidé et oui
c'est une récente à côté de la carrière
de nicoletta a pleuré ce pays qui
démarre
quand tu es parti et on a eu
l'impression on a eu l'impression
qu'elle défende est une cause oui et
alors avait pas de parti pris réel en
fin de compte et nicoletta entre
nicoletta elle ils ont quand même 50 ans
d'écart 50 ans des gars avec 50 ans de
carrière pour nicoletta et je pense qu'à
mon avis il aurait dû être un peu plus
mais la mise en sciant la réserve car
son tour moi je suis comme toi j'ai
toujours le rêve pouvait les gêner moi
j'adore d'abord toutes les personnes un
peu âgées dont on finit le tour laurent
acheter tu parles vers 16h et
c'est ma question c'est du buzz et ces
voix là pour une fois que france
télévisions il ya un peu de buzz de ce
genre là ils sont contents d'ailleurs
c'est marrant de voir la tête de
stéphane bern qui était comme ça et qui
avec son micro derrière lui enfin la
soirée et chiante à mourir tu demande
d'ailleurs qui décide de qui va décider
en vrai donc pourquoi ces gens là qui
sait les dernières s'adonnaient barbara
pratique a fini deuxième bravo à elle
été dur
c'est nul c'est qu'on gagne pas
l'eurovision depuis combien de temps va
excusez moi à l'affiner 2
je répète ma question on ne gagne pas
l'eurovision depuis combien de temps
c'est la deuxième s'est passé même si
rappelez vous de cette phrase enzo
ferrari disait le deuxième c'est le
premier des perdants oui mon jeu mais la
mise en scène est un peu disproportionné
par rapport à son 10è nicoletta il ya
dix jury à chaque fois c'est des
critiques incroyable même pas du tout
pratiquée chez vous c'est génial c'est
génial on émet une petite réserve mais
là on se lève et une mise en scène
totalement disproportionnée comme c'est
un mois mais non parce que là ça fait un
peu manque de respect pour nicoletta qui
était l'un qui comprenait pas ce qui lui
arrive et c'est d'accord il y avait
agressif et lui dit chez moi et moi
alors j'ai voilà alors peut-être pas
tout le monde mais vas-y de vaud désole
le truc cas là c'est qu'elle prône
toujours la la la confiance en soi et
c'est sur l'a9 sociaux sauf que le seul
petit souci c'est qu'elle confond
confiance en soi est un peu le melon
vraiment tu sais quoi mais dites-moi
moyenne à cames ouragans il faut du
temps pour être arrogant moi c'est venu
très vite
oui juste oui parce que moi j'ai eu
l'info du côté de la prod en fait de
l'émission qui se glissent et grands se
félicite en fait de ce bien sûr oui
parce que comme vous l'avez dit laurent
l'a dit tout à l'heure à france télé ils
sont pas trop habitué à avoir ce type de
clash en revanche ils sont plutôt du
côté dizale tu parce qu'ils considèrent
qu nicoletta a eu des mots avec un petit
peu malheureux presse avec il faut
rappeler qu'ils étaient habitués à ce
genre de à ce genre de deux shows on va
dire la f1 avec une interview du monde
qu'elle avait dénoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux et le motel a quitté la france
pour aller s'installer en belgique elle
a fait tout un elle a eu des mots assez
malheureux sur
la juste dit la vider la mélodie
longtemps nié
nicollette a réagi à la polémique avec
élégance elle a dit je voulais dire que
je trouvais le couple est un peu faible
par rapport à la voix merveilleuse
ciprian ne m'a pas laissé le temps de le
dire c'est pas grave y'a pas mort
dernière sans la façon dont elle se
comporte ça la regarde c'est un choix
comme diraient les vulgaires elle agit
comme elle veut on voit là c'était
c'était un peu dur avec lui ça veut dire
le fait que sa personnalité si gentil
colette à la question vous savez que les
bookmakers se tombent rarement et moi
j'ai mon assistant au bureau qui est fan
d'eurovision
et qui donc chaque année s'intéresse et
déjà donc voilà classement et bien
l'ukraine forcément et premier la france
et pas mal fait pas mal et on a rarement
été aussi bien placé on est 10e je
rappelle que ça va jusqu'à 40 les
derniers temps les slovenia tuez les p
je pense que c'est donc voilà mais la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
forcément tout le monde et tous les pays
vont dire tout haut ce ponte ukraine en
hommage à l'ukraine donc conclusion soit
en fait pas l'eurovision non soit on
exclut l'ukraine de l'eurovision dire ce
qu'il faut faire alors en fait ce qui
est intéressant c'est que quelques jours
avant la déclaration de guerre à
l'ukraine dans les bookmakers la chanson
était déjà sorti il était septième ou
huitième dès l'instant où la guerre a
commencé ils se sont retrouvés premier
est bien évidemment dire que c'est
éminemment politique voilà que en effet
l'ukraine va vraisemblablement gagné
c'est déjà presque c'est quand déjà ce
petit
et qu'est ce qu'on fait là moi je peux
attaquer sur le dos des cadres ont la
haine exclure qu'il est beau qu'il
aurait fallu faire c'est faire un super
beau tableau de l'ukraine qui est là
pour avoir en sont entre guillemets une
sorte de prix d'honneur en disant voilà
c'est le prix de sa politique serra mais
non mais parce que merckx et c'est plus
du jeu entre ccq rien surtout non mes
soucis déjà qu'ils seront ruinés parce
que le pays est écrasé demandé de voir
organiser
la vague de terre c'est la vérité a
organisé sa valeur comme ça c'est un
guerrier rabat est ce que vous avez
écouté la chanson de craignait way
qu'elle aura peu folklorique c'est pas
rien la raison c'est que personne n'a
écouté bottes jean mi moi j'en je
garderai l'eurovision mais j'en ferai
une grande soirée pour l'ukraine
caritative à cappelle de fond et y
aurait pas de classement à la fin et où
l'aca serait manières soit répondu
est ce que vous savez et je vais vous
donner l'info qu'à quelques années là le
cren avait déjà gagné parce qu'elle
avait une chanson la cruelle à cri mais
voilà on a mal on a le titre ce pays
bonsoir folie ordinaire mais du coup
j'ai donc ça bien classés
[Musique]
m
jamal a tué la jama là c'est son prénom
c'était donc la star de l'eurovision en
2016 c'est elle voilà elle a remporté le
trophée et depuis l'invasion donc de son
pays par la russie elle est réfugié un
peu politique en turquie ben voilà c'est
pas associée